Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks everyone
that submitted questions for this week’s
Arrow Flash Q&A.
Some of you have started to ask more specific
questions about the mid season crossover episodes
and The CW has released a lot of information
so I’ll start off with that stuff.
Those episodes will air December 2nd and part
2 the next day on the 3rd.
So I might do something special when we get
closer to that.
Question time, careful for spoilers from Arrow
and the Flash this week if you’re not caught
up.
Question 1 - Trek Video asks, Do you think
Harrison Wells is someone from the comics,
is there someone he’s trying to stop?
And do you think he’ll get a scene with
Oliver where he says something about his future?
Yes, I definitely think Harrison Wells is
someone from the comics.
I think Andrew Kreisberg, Geoff Johns and
Greg Berlanti and all the other people writing
on the show made the smart move of doing the
comic book Rebirth story while changing some
of the details enough to maintain some mystery.
Regardless of who Harrison Wells actually
is, I think he’s a time traveler and chose
Harrison Wells as an homage to HG Wells as
in the classic Time Machine book.
So it’s a comic book character using a fake
name.
Here’s the people I think he could be from
most likely to least likely.
And remember, he killed Simon Stagg in cold
blood, he has ice running through his veins.
So he is not a good character.
So rule any superheroes out.
Starting with Eobard Thawne Professor Zoom,
then Impulse, Abra Kadabra and Then a version
of the Rival, the original Reverse Flash.
Your second question: Who or what is Harrison
Wells trying to Stop
I could make an hour long video talking about
how time loops and the multiverse could explain
why Harrison Wells is acting the way he is.
But short version.
The paper with the Crisis at the end of episode
1 is very important.
It says the Barry Allen Flash disappears.
I think the Reverse Flash, I’ll address
him in a sec, I think he went back in time
to erase Barry Allen’s future and was successful.
The timeline we’re seeing unfold on the
show is Harrison Wells going back in time
to make sure Barry Allen does not disappear.
So Harrison Wells is guiding Barry Allen so
that he’ll be able to defeat The Reverse
Flash.
The Big Question is Why, if Harrison Wells
is evil enough to unleash Gorilla Grodd.
Why is
Barry Allen someone he wants to protect?
I think what’s going on is Harrison Wells
is Eobard Thawne, Idolizes the Flash of the
past, gains the powers of the Flash but then
does something bad that leads to the creation
of the Hunter Zolomon Zoom and Zoom is the
one messing with the timeline.
So Harrison Wells still wants to cause trouble
in the future, but he’s trying to prevent
Hunter Zolomon from erasing both Barry Allen
and himself from the timeline.
If Barry Allen never became the Flash, Harrison
Wells would never become Professor Zoom in
the future.
Sorry if that sounds confusing, you have two
Reverse Flashes, one of them is messing with
the timeline in a bad way.
The other Reverse Flash is trying to prevent
that.
That’s a mixture of my theories with the
other best sounding theories I’ve seen.
Episode 9 is called The Man in the Yellow
Suit.
That’s the first time Barry Allen will learn
about the Reverse Flash.
Here’s what I think is going on, I’ll
put this spoiler tag up even though this is
just a theory.
I think that they’re giving Harrison Wells
Professor Zoom’s storyline and they’re
giving Eddie Thawne Hunter Zolomon’s storyline.
They’re just mixing up the names to throw
people off.
As for the Harrison Wells Oliver moment, yes
I definitely think it will happen.
When they do the first part of the Crossover
episode all of Team Arrow will go to Central
City and Star Labs.
It will be like an Arrow Cave Star Labs crossover
moment too.
So yes, keep your eyes peeled for Harrison
Wells dropping a Justice League easter egg.
Question 2 - Vince asks, who do you think
made Roy’s Suit?
Diggle sewing machine maybe?
That’s funny, I think that he contracted
a private company to make it to his specifications.
I don’t think anyone on team arrow physically
made it.
I think Felicity probably helped design it
a little but mostly it was Oliver behind the
design.
Remember during season 1 when Oliver is trying
to get info on Merlyn’s Dark Archer arrows
and Felicity tells him they’re custom made
by this really obscure private company.
It means that he along with Oliver probably
both order their stuff custom.
In Batman Begins Christian Bale had that scene
where he and Alfred talked about ordering
his Batman face mask and the Bat Shaped throwing
stars.
Just one of the benefits of being a rich super
hero or supervillain.
You can pay people to make the crazy things
you dream up in your head.
Ray Palmer, Brandon Routh’s Character is
one of the few exceptions in that he has a
ton of money, but he also has the technical
expertise to make his own tech suit costume.
No word on which episode that will debut but
it’s sounding like it will be the second
half of the season if they just started talking
about the Black Canary costume.
Question 3 - Mahleks asks, do you think Cupid
Freed or Killed the guy at the end?
I think Cupid Killed him, in the comics she
emulates Oliver by trying to solve crimes.
The twist is that she kills all the criminals.
That’s why she appeared at all the crime
scenes in this episode.
She’s following Oliver around or going to
places she knows he’ll show up.
Question 4 - Sam asks, what do you think the
big reveal will be in Episode 9?
Just to clarify episode 8 is the crossover
episode Brave and the Bold, episode 9 is the
mid-season finale.
It’s called The Climb and Alex Kingston
is guest starring again as Laurel’s mom.
In terms of big WTF reveals what I’m hoping
for is Ra’s Al Ghul in Starling, a tease
of the Atom and Black Canary Costumes, China
White Katana follow up and a full explanation
of who killed sara.
Not necessarily why, just the who part.
That’s a lot of stuff but those are all
the biggest reveals I can think of right now.
Think back to the final scene from season
2 episode 9, we got the reveal of Slade being
the big bad in present day and the birth of
The Flash.
So I think we’ll see the birth of a new
superhero.
Either the Atom or Black Canary, maybe both.
And a big villain reveal.
We already know it’s Ra’s Al Ghul, so
he’ll probably do something crazy.
And long long shot, Sara’s Killer.
I don’t think this is very likely but what
if Oliver was the one who killed her and he
was being controlled by someone else without
knowing it.
The unreliability of memory was a big theme
in this week’s episode, so Oliver could
have had his mind messed with by one of the
villains.
That would probably be the biggest WTF reveal.
Question 5 - Anshik asks, do you think we’ll
see the Lazarus Pit?
Based on the way the producers have talked
about superpowers and crazy abilities I don’t
think they’ll do that on Arrow.
If they wanted to explain the Lazarus Pit
they’d do it on The Flash.
For instance, Ray Palmer The Atom.
They said there aren’t any plans to make
him shrink down on Arrow.
They said if they end up doing that, they’d
shrink him down on The Flash.
Just because of the nature of each show.
Flash = Superpowers, Arrow = Crime Drama.
So all the really crazy stuff will happen
on The Flash.
They haven’t said they’re never going
to do Lazarus Pit, but I don’t expect it
to happen this season.
And if they did bring anyone back, I think
it would be Tommy.
But I don’t think they did that either.
Question 6 - Mitzuio asks, if the Flash is
supposed to deal with Time Travel, do you
think we’ll ever see a crossover with future
versions of Team Arrow or Justice League characters?
This season I think they’ll keep time travel
really simple and not throw in too many extra
characters.
I think we’ll see easter eggs for Justice
League stuff though.
Like Harrison Well’s newspaper and verbal
references.
But I’m not expecting to see and Old version
of Oliver or Superman or anything like that.
Question 7 - J Mo asks, do you think we’ll
see Talia Al Ghul?
It’s possible but DC and Warner Brothers
have this weird thing where certain characters
are off limits for the tv shows.
Like Batman and Superman.
Talia also appears in a lot of the animated
movies.
So I don’t think we’ll see her this season.
The same thing happened with Brandon Routh’s
character.
Originally they’d planned for him to be
the Ted Kord Blue Beetle but Warner Brothers
said they had “other plans” for that character.
So they changed it and made Brandon Routh
Ray Palmer instead.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
I think that covers most of the important
stuff.
Here’s some more details on the Crossover
Episodes.
Captain Boomerang will be the reason Team
Arrow goes to Central City and vice versa.
And the reason the first episode is called
Flash versus Arrow is because of a meta human
messing with Barry Allen’s mind.
It’s supposed to be Rainbow Raider or Chroma,
how ever you want to think of him.
Like I said, I’ll try to do some extra special
stuff when that all goes down so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and follow me
on twitter and facebook for updates.
Links for all that stuff in the description.
Next week Cupid versus Arrow, so click here
to catch up on this week’s episode and click
here for this week’s flash episode.
Thanks for watching, boxing glove arrow to
the face, boom.